haven't done the research which i ended
up doing the research kind of on
accident i was an egalitarian but i was
fed up with female behavior and i would
confide to my fiance about the things
that i was frustrated with or that women
are capable of malice because i'd been
primarily bullied by women my whole life
and so he ends up like putting me on
this red pill you know the the
documentary it basically lays out that
women are just as capable as aggression
as as men but um
really i didn't know that
yeah we just do it differently yeah okay
no tell me more i haven't seen the
documentary
okay okay so if you look up the fbi
statistics on dv it's almost 50 50 like
men and women okay right so
women have a tendency to slap more
though
versus like physical assault that was
something i read in a social psychology
textbook but
also women's
typical choice of aggression is indirect
aggression so it's uh
attacking somebody's character or
what is it when people have esteem for
you what is that called i can't it's
coming out of my brain right now like
character reputation okay
yeah yeah okay yeah so that's that's
indirect aggression and that's why
you'll see like some women do you know
false accusations about certain things
but women are just as aggressive as men
and then when you look at the statistics
for child abuse
women are doing it too so that was one
thing that really woke me up that women
do have some
negative aspects to them but it's not
it's not that female nature is good or
bad it's just human nature is what it is
and we're all capable of violence so
that was more so what i was trying to
figure out is
you know
what's wrong with me that i can't
maintain female friendships and come to
find out that i think there's quite a
there's a lot more pathological women
than we really know is the conclusion
that i came to
um
but i wanted to say that when people
look at my relationship and they see the
age gaps they literally think it is the
pinnacle
of the red pill experience you're like
oh my god he got a younger woman he's
50. he has money
uh and that is such a unicorn fantasy
and i'm 27 now but you know one day i'm
gonna be 37 like these looks only last
for so long
no and that's
it's not about the money we've said it
before and again it is not about the
money alone it is about
the character that is like built in
order to acquire money i would say
um unless you're a straight-up gold
digger which i can very much tell you or
not so
oh i mean who knows i could get a tumor
and hyper me could just ruin my life i
might just steal this dude's r8 who
knows catch me on the news
really quick really quick uh ladies
thank you for telling the nude truth i
found you two on donovan and i'm glad i
did keep telling the hard truths thank
you so much for the donation all
donations go towards new mics for um and
a new sound board so i can host eight
girls in my living room for a podcast
that we're gonna do weekly is supposed
to be today sadly there was a storm so
next week we're gonna we're gonna
do it but thank you ninja watcher for
life okay sorry
no i i'm all about this um yeah i know
when we get to talking we just kind of
kind of can't stop
um but i also i also don't want to over
talk you on your own platform and make
sure you see stuff
oh no i am that's like when i invite
people i want you guys to talk
you openly say you are hypergamous
yeah like what's wrong with it what what
what i'm supposed to do be with a dude
that makes forty thousand dollars a year
and raise my three kids like with what i
need like
well i think everyone even men too they
everyone wants to get the best mate they
can like on both ends like i don't think
anyone's saying i hope i can find
someone that i
can do better than i think men are just
the problem is when it gets unrealistic
and i think that's where men get mad
when women like won't settle won't
compromise but
i don't see anything wrong with wanting
to be with the best like fit for you
right so hypergamy gets a bad reputation
because women right now we have
unfettered hypergamy like the
we like stuff you don't think hypergamy
is real do me a favor after the live
stream go to the mall look around i want
you to count as many female humans that
you see and why you count as many male
humans as you see tell me we ain't out
here shopping it's true go to goodwill
go to ross
it's full of chicks so we we just like
stuff
is my my perspective on it and also it
for the women that don't think that
hypergamy is real how come every time
one of your home girls graduates from
law school or medical school the first
thing they buy is a gucci bag or some
louboutins like
very obvious for my pergamos
it's such a waste of money too i could
you will not catch me you will not catch
me buying oh no
you will not catch me buying that
it's a lot of fun too because i was
hanging out with my grandma
uh last week which a couple days ago and
we were out shopping
and she's literally trying to buy her
11th perfume and she doesn't need it and
she's just grabbing the stuff out like
oh this is so cute and it's it's female
nature in action hypergamy isn't bad
it's just
it's
it can get you burned and that's why i
say women don't settle with men because
that is disingenuous to the value of men
really what you do is you take a deal
and you take a deal that makes sense the
man offers you his resources you offer
him this in return you make an agreement
you abide by the agreement and
everything is good and kosher
the reason why women are hypocrites you
already know a lot of this stuff but i
guess maybe your audience might not know
is uh we have a globalized dating market
if i wanted to
want right now
i could find a millionaire across the
world who would fly me out the thing is
is that the same guy that's going to
commit to me so let's say
i lose my hypergamous mind and i just
leave my man for another man who makes
way more money maybe i decide to play
that stupid game because it's dumb
the the man that i'm running into who i
guess we would say like high value or
something
he is going to know that i'm a woman and
incapable of commitment and capable of
judgment so he's probably not going to
reproduce with me he probably most
likely will not marry me
right so you just have to know when to
take a deal with someone and and we were
saying earlier it's not necessarily
about the money so my man could lose his
job but i'm not worried because i'm very
confident that within 30 days he would
find some other form of gainful
employment and we can downsize
right i'm not expecting him to become
this homeless heroin addict overnight or
something it's just let's just keep it
normal
oh no it's it's the same thing my dad he
right before in 2007 2006 he bought a
neighborhood with their life savings
and then the housing market crashed so
they put everything all of the money
they'd made and they were not as like
well-off as they are like now back then
like their business wasn't even doing
close to as good and like my mom didn't
leave him because he was you know
i don't want to say he was broke because
we still lived in the same house but
like we were very close to losing
everything
and
uh like men value loyalty like they want
someone that's gonna stick with them
through thick and thin
yo it's crazy it's crazy what a man will
put up with for some loyalty
like
you know my relationship looks really
good on the internet but i'm still a
woman i'm still emotional and i'm
telling you sometimes the way i just be
absolutely in my feelings crying on the
couch over something small like i'm a
loser
you know and he's just sitting there
taking it saying it's okay
it's all right there there i can't do
that at work ain't no manager or
supervisor gonna hold me down but a man
will sit there and listen to your crazy
rant for 30 minutes
just because you're there you're solid
about nothing about mountains
about everything
i saw this commercial that just it was
the kid like